la nouvelle extension de vélizy 2 est
terminé après l'ouverture début mars de
son nouveau cinéma le centre commercial
a inauguré quelques jours plus tard une
halte gourmande au total 23 restaurant
pour manger sur place ou sur le pouce se
sont implantés dans ce nouvel espace de
5000 m² il y avait de fortes attentes un
autre clientèle pour avoir plus d'offres
de restauration c'était une demande
depuis des années parce qu'on a quand
même 50 mille salariés qui travaillent
ici tous les jours à proximité donc le
midi forcément mais également le
week-end parce que nos pics d'activité
sont le samedi et maintenant le dimanche
et on a une clientèle qui souhaitent se
restaurer le midi le soir avant d'aller
au cinéma et on avait un besoin un
besoin important on avait dix sept
points de restauration donc là on passe
à 40
en parallèle de la restauration les
gérants misent également sur les loisirs
ici cette salle d'arcade en réalité
virtuelle propose de vous immerger dans
un monde 2.0 donc vous voyez derrière
moi mais les différentes stations
délimiter chaque client est équipé d'un
casque et de deux manettes reproduire le
mouvement des mains grâce à ça il va se
plonger dans le monde de son choix
seul ou à plusieurs donc ça peut être
simplement de l'exploration si vous
voulez visiter une ville dans le monde
n'importe où dans le monde
si vous voulez jouer à différentes
choses voulait faire de l'escaladé sur
la baie d'halong au vietnam ou sur les
parois rocheuses des alpes ont des
paysages magnifiques vous pouvez pour
cette nouvelle extension les
propriétaires ont dû mettre près de 140
millions d'euros sur la table
au total plus de 300 emplois ont été
créés